[Musique]
ce soir je vais vous parler de voyage
plus précisément du tour du monde que
j'ai réalisé en auto stop entre 2007 et
2013 lorsqu'on a demandé de venir à
cette conférence tedx et qu'on m'a
annoncé le thème de la soirée la
conquête
je me suis demandé en quoi mon
expérience de voyage se rapproche-t-elle
du terme de conquête
parce que la conquête pour moi la
première chose qui me venait à l'esprit
c'était comme vous l'avez dahu
d'ailleurs eu dans votre description de
ce soir des épopées sanguinolente létale
martial ce qui venait aussi dans mon
esprit c'était des histoires d'extension
géographique de conquêtes guerrières en
tant que norme ans j'avais aussi la
vision l'image de guillaume le
conquérant qui me venait à l'esprit et
je me demandais qu'est ce que une mille
ans auparavant avait pu être les
aventures du duc de normandie
évidemment encore une fois des images
d'armes et de l'âme qui s'entrechoquent
déco roxy des entrailles qui pourrissent
sous le ciel normaux donc en bref une
vision pas très optimiste de la chose
j'ai eu 12 couverts à un dictionnaire le
dictionnaire du cn et rtl le centre
national de ressources textuelles et
lexicales que nous appellerons ce soir
le dictionnaire en ligne
au terme de conquête qui m'a ensuite
mené au terme conquérir actions de
conquérir conquérir le premier mot qui
la première description qui venaient se
rendre maître par les armes encore une
fois une vision très proche de ma
première image initiale
un peu plus loin une autre définition
s'efforçait de prendre possession de
soi-même s'efforcer de prendre
possession de soi même il y avait
peut-être là quelque chose
j'essaie de me remémorer ce qui a 10 ans
émerger dans mon esprit d'adolescents
j'étais arrivé à la fin de mes études
j'étais en face d'une vie
professionnelle qui se propage qui se
présentait devant moi et j'essaie de
trouver un but de vie j'essaie aussi de
trouver un peu de bonheur dans magie
d'essayer de faire ça avec plaisir la
notion de plaisir était là mais il y en
avait peu à ce moment là de ma vie je
peux poser des questions
essayez de trouver un sens à tout ça
mais mon état d'esprit
j'ai peut-être cité un certain jonathan
lehmann c'était un ancien avocat wall
street et il disait exactement quelque
chose qui se rapprocher ma vision de la
chose à ce moment là ça faisait 5
millions qu'on joue au jeu de la
civilisation
on avait réussi à envoyer des hommes sur
la lune on avait réussi à cloner des
animaux on avait créé de l'intelligence
artificielle et pourtant on avait fait
aucun progrès du tout sur le bonheur on
avait même régressé à en juger le nombre
de suicides
le nombre de dépressions et à en juger
aussi par le spleen ambiant c'est un peu
mon état d'esprit à ce moment là de ma
vie pourtant j'ai essayé
de créer des expériences pour trouver du
bonheur l'une d'entre elles
c'était l'auto-stop la première fois que
j'ai découvert cette manière de voyager
c'est au pays de galles j'étais parti là
bas pour apprendre l'anglais
je travaillais dans un hôtel chaque jour
j'ai essayé de créer les interactions de
créer des événements est l'une d'entre
elles ces expériences me ménard a posé
le pousse au bord de la route au pays de
galles j'étais avec des amis on était
allé visiter un village environnant le
bus venait de partir et le prochain été
pendant plusieurs heures
je suis parti seul avec le défi
d'arriver avant eux bien mon a fallu au
bout de cinq minutes un véhicule
s'arrêter une ford mondeo bleus avec un
gallois dedans ce gallois me permis
d'apprendre trois choses ce jour si la
première c'est que en quelques minutes
passées avec lui j'en apprenais beaucoup
plus sur la culture galloises quand
plusieurs mois passés à travailler dans
le restaurant
il m'avait parlé de sa culture du
langage gallois de ce qu'il faisait le
week-end avec sa famille la deuxième
chose c'était lié à la sensation est la
vision de l'auto stop qui étaient
communément considéré aujourd'hui encore
comme non recommandables quelle émotion
pure est phénoménal d'éprouver de la
liberté j'aurais pu aller où je voulais
quand je voulais comment je voulais est
ce juste enlevé l'on pousse la troisième
c'était que économiquement c'était
possible de le faire à ce moment là
j'avais beaucoup de temps dans ma vie
j'avais peu d'argent et techniquement
j'aurais pu aller jusqu'à moscou de
cette façon-là 2006
je rentre en france je me pose une
question
j'ai deux chemins à choisir la gauche je
mens conventionnelle continuer des
études reprendre le travail
avoir une femme des enfants une maison à
droite vides aventures de rêve
pourquoi pas pousser le concept de
l'auto-stop un peu plus loin pourquoi
pas aller faire le tour du monde en
auto-stop 2006 la décision est un peu
compliquée à prendre parce que j'ai
encore ses peurs au fond de moi la peur
de l'inconnu
la peur des médias qui sont stationnés à
lise l'information est ce que je vais me
retrouver en terrain guerrier justement
est-ce que je vais manquer de quelque
chose est-ce que je vais manquer
d'argent de nourriture
et puis la pression sociale aussi
comment revenir à une vie normale si je
pars faire un voyage comme celui ci
difficile je prends une décision pour
moi c'est un compromis je continuerai
les études mais des études de tourisme
clairement j'étais partie par là mais
pourtant je perds pas d'idée cette
notion d' aventure
pendant un an je continue de lire des
récits de voyage jack kerouac sur la
route sandra bury jour qui a qui a péri
rennais sur notre planète en auto-stop
également durant les années 60 70
il m'apporte pas de balises sur le
chemin de droite par contre il arrive à
répondre à une seule question la plus
importante c'est que c'est possible de
le faire
il est simplement possible voyager
autour du monde
en auto stop je prends donc la décision
le jour où je l'annonçais mes parents
nous étions à table
papa maman je sais ce que je vais faire
finalement finalement je vais faire un
tour du monde en auto-stop
et pourtant ce jour là c'est là où tout
a vraiment basculé
je l'avais dit il fallait que je le
fasse je continue mes lectures je me
renseigne sur les visages discute avec
des personnes qui ont voyagé elle même
le rêve commence à prendre conscience
établi mon sac
c'est ce que j'utiliserai pendant cinq
ans de magie très peu de choses comme
vous pouvez le voir mais l'essentiel
l'essentiel pour moi c'est d'être léger
parce que je vais beaucoup marcher entre
les différents véhicules
je commencerai avec un sac sur le dos et
je rajouterais 1 à la moitié du voyage
en face de moi celui de sur le dos il y
aura dans le coffre des véhicules celui
qui sera en face de moi restera avec moi
quand j'irai dans l'habitacle des
véhicules puis l'essentiel de
l'essentiel le passeport la carte
d'identité
la carte bleue il faut un minimum aussi
de sécurité financière je ne peux pas
être dépendant des personnes qui me
verront leurs portes
il faudra tout de même que je puisse
subvenir à mes besoins naturels que ce
soit la nourriture parfois l'hébergement
mais pas pour l'auto stop je continue
l'auto stop en me préparant je fais un
tour du monde
un tour de france en auto stop puis un
tour d'europe et c'est là vraiment que
la manière de voyager prend tout son
sens j'ai pas envie à ce moment là
d'entrée d'un transactions commerciales
je peux garder la pureté de l' échange
en ne payant pas pour le transport et
non pas sans papa on va dire une
transaction commerciale avec mon
interlocuteur je rajouterais
un projet pédagogique et le 8 octobre
2007 je pars d'une école avec qui je
resterai en contact
il me poseront des questions pendant le
voyage je leur répondrais sur les pays
sur les différentes civilisations
rencontrer puis après cette cérémonie
d'adieu un ami me dépose au péage de
dozulé à la sortie de quand je lève le
pouce j'attends dix minutes
un camion s'arrête et c'était parti cinq
ans et demi à faire du stop passant par
l'europe l'afrique l'amérique du nord
l'amérique du sud l'océanie l'asie le
asie centrale
retour en europe cinq ans et pas
seulement en auto-stop aussi en camion
stop en moto stop pour la partie
terrestre pour camions sur le camion
comme ici au soudan
mais pour traverser les océans pourquoi
ne pas pousser la chose de ce qu'elle
allait faire du bateau stop et si
j'étais devenu on va dire un équipier
jeu couper les pommes de terre
je gage et prenez les gardes durant la
nuit pour être sûr que notre embarcation
ne heurte pas une autre et ceci pendant
plusieurs mois quatre mois pour le
pacifique deux mois pour l'atlantique
mais ç'a toujours en stop
parfois c'est un peu plus difficile
parfois c'était pas la saison faudra
naviguer comme entre la nouvelle-zélande
et l'australie et m'a fallu négocier
avec des compagnies de cargos entre
l'australie l'indonésie avec des
compagnies commerciales aérienne et là
c'est plusieurs semaines a envoyé des
centaines d'e-mails aux compagnies
aériennes
la nation de trouver le bon
interlocuteur assure tout en essayant de
trouver son contact et obtenu une
réponse positive le plus beau coup
peut-être ce fut cette traversée
aérienne
j'avais inventé on va dire l'e-mail du
pdg dont plus tôt j'avais essayé et 20
combinaisons possibles et j'avais trouvé
par hasard à son e-mail il m'avait
répondu dans la foulée en m'envoyant le
lendemain un ticket d'avion pour aller à
bali mais sans mes compagnons les
humains je n'aurais pu aller que on va
dire très peu éloigné du périphérique de
caen il m'a fallu donc recourir à l'aide
de plusieurs personnes sur cette route
ici les familles africaines qui m'a
hébergé une soirée parce que comme
l'escargot
je ne portais pas ma maison sur le dos
il fallait chaque soir répondre à cette
question existentielle
ou est ce que j'allais dormir ici en
ethiopie ici aux etats unis un jour où
je n'ai pas trouvé l'endroit où dormir
ce qu'il faut savoir avant de passer par
la difficulté c'est que voyager en
auto-stop m'a permis d'avoir accès à une
vision du monde de la part des personnes
qui habitaient les endroits où je
passais donc chaque habitant m'expliquer
sa ville chaque habitant a pu expliquer
son village et à grâce à ça j'ai acquis
une vision du monde qui était basée sur
la vision de ses habitants là j'ai
construit une vision du monde basé sur
la diversité de chaque civilisation qui
m'a expliqué les endroits où je passais
avec leurs propres histoires très
différentes d
l'histoire qui aurait pu être racontée
par un gouvernement ou par un office de
tourisme
mais évidemment voyager de cette façon
là n'a pas été non plus sans difficulté
et si vous pouvez avoir un aperçu aux
états unis où l'auto stop était
interdite pendant six mois 35 fois je me
suis fait arrêter par la police
il faut de la volonté 1 au venezuela je
me suis fait agresser par la police arme
au poing du mont dérobés mais peu mais
peu de bien que j'avais c'était
c'est-à-dire un ordinateur un appareil
photo la police quand même à qui allez
je me plaindre la communication aussi
est une difficulté
le concept de l'auto-stop n'existe
vraiment que dans certains endroits du
monde
on connaît le levé du pouce en france le
mourre auto-stop existe mais il ya des
endroits où le mot n'existe même pas le
concept n'existe pas non plus il m'a
fallu utiliser des traductions du terme
de l'auto stop ou est ce que ça voulait
dire pour ensuite le présenter au chaque
conducteur évidemment parfois le pouce
ne fonctionnait pas comme en iran où le
pouce représente le doigt du milieu en
france ne pas se tromper doit une fois
que le véhicule s'arrêter je pouvais
finalement lui montré la lettre qu'il
pouvait à ce moment là répond de manière
positive ou négative
et moi je pouvait éventuellement avancé
comme je vous disais trouver un endroit
où ces bergers la nuit c'était également
une difficulté j'utilisais quatre
techniques donc l'hospitalité naturel
que vous avez vu un peu auparavant comme
en afrique quand cela ne fonctionnait
pas j'utilisais parfois
coacher fing un site internet où les
personnes vous héberge ces jeux c'est
gratuit ça vous permet surtout d'avoir
un échange interculturel
j'arrivais chez eux je leur proposais
des histoires de voyages des photos de
ma famille de mon pays et des endroits
que j'avais traversé et on échange
j'avais un endroit où passer la nuit d
hôtel bon marché comme ici au soudan
oui oui c'est un hôtel il était arrivé à
certains moments que je ne trouve aucun
endroit où dormir
et du coup je dormais simplement à la
belle étoile
ici ou sous dont pourtant et si ce n'est
pas des fois où j'ai dormi dehors
c'était on va dire un motel à la
soudanaise
les conducteurs de camion utilisé cette
façon dormir il demandait simplement un
lit à la station essence très pratique
pour un auto stoppeur au lever du soleil
je pouvais déjà rockets khaled des
conducteurs de camions j'ai également
voulu rendre en plus de ces histoires de
voyages aux personnes qui m'héberge et
parfois je voulais rendre aussi à ce
qu'on m'avait ce qu'ont apporté chaque
jour de l'aide pratique logistique mais
aussi des connaissances donc j'allais
depuis depuis le début du voyage rendent
visite des écoles sur ma route et je
leur faisais une présentation du du
voyage alors je leur ai expliqué
l'histoire de ce voyage et j'essayais de
partager avec les enfants quelques
visions du monde
certains des enfants le pourrons
peut-être jamais voyagé grâce ou à cause
de leur passeport qui le contraint
rougès je pense malheureusement à rester
dans leur propre pays
on est très chanceux d'avoir un
passeport français on peut aller où on
veut et où même en faire un tour du
monde ici en chine par exemple
faire une présentation des enfants
chinois ce voyage il m'a permis
d'apprendre beaucoup de choses sur le
monde sur les différentes civilisations
sur moi même j'ai appris que la sérénité
ce hacker dont l'exemption de la peur
que l'exemption de l'apr s'acquiert dans
la connaissance mais que l'ignorance de
son prochain facilite la création d'un
climat de peur que la peur mènent à la
violence au conflit à la destruction
mais qu'en conséquence apprendre les uns
des autres
c'est la meilleure façon de se tolérer
et de vivre en paix j'essaie aujourd'hui
d'en faire un moto de ma vie
d'aujourd'hui de pratiquer la curiosité
d'en apprendre le maximum parce que je
pense cela peut résoudre certains
problèmes à mon échelle j'essaie juste
de peut-être montrer l'exemple et de me
construire en tant que personne c'est ce
que ce voyage là m'a appris et surtout à
prendre possession de moi même comme le
dictionnaire en ligne disait c'est donc
là une conquête
merci
[Applaudissements]